so one event i would like to highlight
is focusing on drones drones have been
the hot topic in the past years but the
drone revolution is far from over
every six months we are seeing new
applications from lifestyle gadgets to
medical services to food delivery and
i'm glad
to speak now with one of the top experts
in this field
and this is christian yanke partner and
advisor at drone masters
and i'll talk to him about the
opportunities in teaching the young
generation good morning christian nice
meeting you
uh what role good morning playing
in education are drones already being
used in school classes and if so in
which subjects
well we have seen that in in some areas
in the
so-called stem subject science
technology engineering and math
and in in some schools it's slowly
starting to getting adopted
so teachers are looking in those small
robotic devices
such as this one here as a tool as an
educational tool
to bring the learning outcomes and then
to talk about
the the challenges of the future
robot robotics digitalization and and
data analytics many things can be
covered
with those small aerial robots and this
is what we would like to
talk about and introduce to the teachers
that will participate in our teacher
education
tell me chris why are drones such a good
learning device
well drones contribute uh more to the
robotic learning and to the the
challenges
of the future we see in in robotics and
automation
than ground robots we have seen ground
robots in school since many years but
three-dimensional movement and and the
opportunity to
remotely pilot drones but also to
program them
offers uh different avenues in several
areas for
very very important fields of the topic
so starting really from
mechatronics and robotics going into the
field of autonomy
programming coding and even into machine
learning
and what chris are the most exciting
developments in the drone market
well in the overall drone market it's
more dominating currently our
field of the news as earlier it started
with aerial photography then it went
over
applications in agriculture and as you
have seen in logistics as well
and it really goes now in areas where
the the people will fly in not yeah
drones they are not unmanned but they
are moving people flying cars
electro-vertical mobility
that is the um those are some of the
aspects of the future and
students and graduates really need to be
prepared for that and this is what we
are trying to do
to bring that to education and to
introduce those new challenges those new
opportunities to the young generation
well looking forward to learn more in
your event during the berlin science um
thank you so much christian